[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois par skype depuis
bamako au mali aminata traoré qui a été
ministre de la culture et du tourisme du
mali et qui a été aussi candidate au
poste de secrétaire général de l'onu
mais c'est antonio guterres est ce qui a
été nommée elle est co auteur de
l'afrique mutilés
viol de l'imaginaire ou de l'afrique
humiliée aminata dramane traoré bon sur
bonjour nous allons parler de l'afrique
à l'épreuve du coronavirus de l'avenir
de l'afrique et du mali où se trouve où
la france se bat contre les djihadistes
depuis sept ans sans succès alors
commençons par l'afrique à l'épreuve du
grenat virus les journaux français
s'étonnent beaucoup de la résistance de
l'afrique
je rappelle que l'afrique ne représente
jusqu'à présent en tout cas que 0,6 pour
cent des cas de décès du co vide 19 dans
le monde alors qu'elle elle compte 17 8
17% de la population mondiale
alors comment vous explique cela en
afrique
bon nous n'avons pas d'explications nous
n'agissons pas nous regardons et ce mal
s'emparer du monde et le bouleverser
dans tous les sens et nous avons
effectivement est entendue disons des
prévisions et parfois et des nous
annoncer les quatorze parfois mais la
réalité c'est que et pour l'instant nous
gérons nous comptons nous menons aussi
on a franchi semble-t-il vendredi
dernier le cap des cent mille et
infections mais pour l'instant c'est ce
n'est pas en tout cas ce que nous a
prédit en effet
le confinement c'est impossible en
afrique le confinement strict comme on
l'a connu par exemple en france
je crois que les gens en afrique ont des
revenus quotidiens on doit partir tous
les jours sans sortir de chez soi pour
aller travailler pour ramener quelque
chose à manger
et puis en plus les gens de ce qu'on
appelle des emplois informels aucune
aucune couverture sociale qui lui est
lié le confinement n'existe pas en
afrique je crois qu'il existe en afrique
du sud mais c'est tout oui en afrique du
sud eux y croient qu'un certain nombre
de pays qui essaie mais si c'est
intenable
c'est socialement économiquement et
politiquement intenable
parce que et dans la quasi totalité du
continent et 60 80 % des actifs se sont
dans le secteur dit informel donc et les
gens vivent au jour le jour ne sont pas
équipés n'ont pas les moyens de
constituer des stocks
donc c'est cet explosif d'exiger que les
gens ne sortent pas donc le confinement
n'est pas possible et il ya des efforts
considérables qui sont faits en ce
moment et en matière d'information de la
population quant au lavage des mains le
port de masques et les états ont fait
des efforts considérables
c'est suivi avec une rigueur dans
certains milieux et parfois c'est
extrêmement difficile
l'absence de de protection sociale on
l'a dit l'absence d'assurance santé le
manque d'infrastructures sanitaires
si si tout à coup
l'épidémie flambé en afrique comme la
flambée ailleurs ça pourrait être
catastrophique c'est ce que tout le
monde redoutait d'ailleurs oui non si
nous oublions cette éventualité cette
évolution est de la situation en priant
pour que elle n'arrive pas mais c'est
clair que en termes de nombre de lits de
personnel soignant
bon c'est parce est pas satisfaisant
c'est loin d'être satisfaisant et
bonjour
effectivement la question de la prise en
charge des malades
et là aussi a rien de comparable avec la
situation en europe et pour des raisons
et quelque part c'est vrai toutes
proportions gardées
et quand nous voyons aujourd'hui le
débat autour des infrastructures
sanitaires la bataille des personnels de
santé nous le disons bon et c'est
relatif mais en fait et nous retrouvons
et dans les pays développés et le même
schéma qu ici parce que nous nous sommes
fait les politiques d'ajustement
structurel et ont quand même largement
contribué à l'état de déliquescence et
des systèmes de santé
est ce qu'il ya où mali alors là il ya
des des chiffres un peu plus
redoutable qui sont tombées il y aurait
une augmentation de 32% en une semaine
de 32% des cas confirmés pas des morts 1
des cas confirmés sur tout le continent
africain je crois pas que le mali fasse
partie des pays qui ont subi une grosse
hausse cette semaine
non non je ne sais pas nous n'avons pas
enregistré une grosse hausse
nous ne te rends compte du fait aussi
ici comme partout ailleurs est ce que
mes hommes puisqu'il est il est dit que
est la plus de 90% des cas les gens sont
guérissent en fait les gens guérissent
les cas asymptomatiques et ceux qui se
tombent malades qui se relève et sans
savoir que c'est le cours n'a est
toujours est il que dans la pratique les
gens qui meurent nous connaissons un peu
nous avons tous se ruent des parents ou
des proches qui sont partis mais c'est
par rapport à aux schémas ce que nous
voyons ailleurs ça n'a rien à voir
alors ce qui inquiète le il ya eu deux
groupes rock de gros progrès dans le
domaine de la santé en afrique
on est parvenu à réduire la mortalité
à quoi l'attribuez vous
ce progressé au cours de ces dernières
décennies moi je pense que il ya des
efforts considérables qui ont été faits
en matière de soins de santé
même si et l'accessibilité des services
demeure et des médicaments demeure
problématique pour et les ménages à
revenus à revenus faibles et en milieu
rural est d'autant plus que le schéma
qui a été proposé à partir de la
décennie 80 dans le cadre comme il est
dit dans le cadre de politiques
néolibérales
c'était deux situés partout et là le
principe du recouvrement des coûts c'est
à dire la participation de la population
et aux coûts des soins de santé
donc les médicaments ne sont pas
accessibles pour le plus grand nombre
et vous on sait par ailleurs aussi que
30 à 40% des médicaments et qu'ils sont
et qu'on trouve sur le marché ici sont
des faux et donc on a des problèmes les
problèmes sont réels mais nous essayons
de faire le maximum d'informations et en
matière de prévention et de déformations
et d'éducation des populations
donc il ya eu de vrais progrès il ya une
vraie réduction de la mortalité mais
justement on se on se s'inquiète un peu
que la focalisation actuelle sur le
coronavirus ne ruine les efforts qui ont
été faits pour lutter contre les autres
maladies alors que ce soit des maladies
infectieuses ou des maladies
parasitaires est ce que ça vous inquiète
aussi
vous personnellement aminata traoré puis
surtout à pays comme le vôtre le mali
oui c'est clair que les contenus de la
modicité et des moyens de l'état et les
mêmes du nombre d'hôpitaux et
d'infrastructures d'accueil des malades
il ya certaines pathologies comme le
paludisme et on le sert tu es en tout
cas puisque le corona et il ya le vih
sida il ya et de la maladie chronique et
les gens qui ont besoin des hôpitaux des
lits d'hôpitaux disent que 10 dont 2
d'être des laissés pour contre parce que
et les ressources une bonne partie des
ressources et de la tension est
consacrée au corona en ce moment ce qui
n'est pas spécifique à l'afrique
d'ailleurs sans compter que et sans
oublier que beaucoup de gens évitent
aussi d'aller dans les hôpitaux de peur
d'être contaminés de ce fait on pourrait
redouter qu'ils aient davantage de morts
que latéral que de mort directe du que
8,19 par exemple en afrique c'est clair
et c'est marc collatéral est disque de
et proviendront certainement des
conséquences économiques des
conséquences économiques et sociales
et si les difficultés et les pénuries
alimentaires vont trop loin nous avons
nous redoutons des soulèvements lié aux
difficultés d'approvisionnement des
populations des sites où les couches les
plus vulnérables premières conséquences
économiques que de la pandémie
c'est l'argent des migrants
l'argent de la diaspora africaine qui
est actuellement est en europe ou
ailleurs et qui souvent d'ailleurs à des
emplois est au travail au noir donc n'a
plus d'emploi il ne peut plus envoyer
d'argent au pays
oui c'est la double peine pour
s'agissant des migrants et parce que là
où ils sont
il ya des chances qu'ils perdent leur
emploi est ici là où ils viennent en
aide à leurs parents et les difficultés
et s'amoncellent
donc comme je le disais et les styles et
genres doute et la dimension sanitaire
de la gestion de cette crise et mais la
dimension économique importante compte
tenu de la structure de nos économies et
le fait que le secteur informel absorbe
une bonne partie des actifs et ça c'est
l'une des caractéristiques de nos
économies l'autre caractéristique c'est
que et les transferts de fonds des
migrants qui dépasse d'ailleurs le
public au développement
7 les transferts de fonds des migrants
et il constitue vraiment ici une
question d'oxygène c'est ça qui permet à
beaucoup de pays est vraiment de
respirer et cet argent
et contrairement à l'aide publique au
développement et pénètre les milieux les
plus reculées le travailleur vous voyez
énormément de travailleurs émigrés les
100 euros 200 euros par mois qu'ils
envoient et parviennent est vraiment à
pas dans les familles et l'achat de
médicaments la question de la solidarité
il sait pas ce qu'on peut faire et on
est confrontés les maladies chroniques
plus le corona et pas de transfert de
fonds et pas de battre pas d'emploi
localement et ses salles et cela
constitue la véritable difficulté paul
et les dettes
on parle de d'effacer les dettes des
pays les plus pauvres
mais on parle de nous
quant à nous les pays riches d'augmenter
notre dette considérablement le coût de
cette pandémie va être considérable mais
pour ce qui est de l'afrique
qu'en est il mais on a recours aux mêmes
solutions et la balle je vois que vous
avez sorti le carnet de chèques et les
banques centrales et déclare un des
milliers de milliards d'euros on est
ébahi en voyant tout ça s'est beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent et dans notre
situation et nous avons la question de
l'annulation de la dette a surgi votre
président a parlé mais et plusieurs
chefs d'état africains l'ont demandé et
moi je plaide effectivement pour
l'annulation de la dette de l'afrique
est pour l'instant et les le club de
paris certains est d'ailleurs consciente
et des prêts des suspensions la
suspension du paiement et des détours de
désintérêt de taux d'intérêt qui absorbé
une part substantielle d'ailleurs et
d'une recette et d'exploitation donc et
c'est clair que nous allons être
confrontés la fcc la gestion de la dette
extérieure at remparts et les spas
travers des politiques d'austérité et
qui a qui est à l'origine d'une bonne
partie des maux du continent et il a
fallu licencier les opérer des coupes
sombres dans les dépenses publiques
exactement comme chez vous et le nom on
ne recrute plus et les diplômés sans
emploi et les l'immigration ou même une
part considérable de ceux qui aiment se
convertissent au djihadisme tout cela a
un lien avec la question du financement
du développement dans le financement
public c'est le talon d'achille est de
nos pays
maintenant et si à la faveur du corona
il faut recourir à la dette
mais bon moi je dis pourquoi pas parce
que dans l'immédiat on n'a pas les
ressources nécessaires pour faire face à
une pandémie à laquelle les gens ne
s'attendaient pas mais seulement est ce
que et pourquoi les gens plaide pour
l'annulation et pure et simple
on nous dit c'est pas envisageable parce
que c'est ça fait pas bien de ne pas
payer sa dette parce que et les laits ce
qui les agences de notation b au gré
mais c'est complexe c'est extrêmement
difficile
cette question a été posée par thomas
sankara au niveau de l'uia et la
question est aujourd'hui une question
brûlante qui est sur la table s'est
posée par et là une nouvelle génération
de chefs d'état mais moi j'aimerais bien
en tout cas que et cette fois ci je me
suis battu je fais partie des militants
altermondialistes qui se sont battus
pour l'annulation de la dette
on a eu droit à l'initiative pays
pauvres très endettés et qui n'a rien
réglé aujourd'hui l'initiative du g20 et
qui consiste qui pour l'instant n'a
obtenu que la suspension c'est à dire le
report mais ça ne règle pas le problème
et le problème la question fondamentale
du financement du développement
c'est pour ça que et l'après coup vide
je l'espère dans le cadre de la
réflexion sur la propre vide en afrique
nous allons prendre à bras le corps
cette question de la dette de l'afrique
elle filme quel modèle de développement
à travers et par le truchement de kehl
et modes de financement de ce
développement
on ne parle pas que de la dette de
l'afrique heureusement on parle aussi de
sa croissance
on parle d'une croissance moyenne autour
de 5% du continent africain par an c'est
énorme 5% pour pour des pays comme le
nôtre qui n'ont pas atteint un tel
chiffre depuis très très très très très
très très longtemps
alors d'abord est-ce que vous la
ressentez cette croissance en afrique
aminata est ce que la population profite
mais c'est à cette croissance et elle
vous proposez vous
elle est brandie à levante c'est une
croissance qui profite d'abord à bukavu
entreprises les multinationales et sont
les principales gagnantes de et de cette
croissance 6 et elle avait un impact et
sur les conditions de vie et sur
l'économie réelle et on n'aurait pas eu
droit et atteindre 2 morts en
méditerranée on aura même peut-être même
pas eu droit et à ce qu'on appelle la
crise sécuritaire ici le lait c'est
pourquoi que de cette croissance
elles sont aujourd'hui malheureusement
ce qui risque de souffrir également
c'est là le paradoxe c'est un modèle qui
ne profite pas à l'immense majorité des
africains mais l'arrêt est brutal et du
modèle et de ce processus là mais en
difficulté et ses gagnants et les
victimes
et c'est là où il faut faire extrêmement
attention et il ya la supercherie
consiste à dire que et les conséquences
économiques et sociales est de la
pandémie sont telles que l'afrique sera
l'afrique sera la région du monde qui va
en souffrir le plus mais c'est pas à
fait et le virus est comme cela était
bien loin large et non seulement est
révélateur et de dysfonctionnements même
de la faillite du modèle mais le virus
et et aggravent des inégalités et des
situations existantes
les difficultés économiques et sociales
qui sont sur la table aujourd'hui
préexiste et préexistait à la pandémie
donc et il faut remettre à plat
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on appelait le
développement la croissance
quelle croissance profit de qui comment
se fait-il que l afrique continue je ne
dis pas qu'il n'y a pas de gagnant bien
sûr il ya des gagnants
il ya des gens qui ont bien compris
qu'ils s'inscrivent dans dents dans
cette dynamique
que d'une afrique soit disant émergentes
je n'y crois pas si elle est en tout cas
elle est pour une infime minorité de la
population
l'immense majorité bas de laine pourtant
vous avez l'air de dire que cet argent
ou du mois cette croissance est captée
par les multinationales pas seulement
les nôtres
j'imagine les chinoises aussi en
profitent mais le problème de la
répartition des revenus à l'échelle d'un
continent comme l'afrique n'est pas de
la seule responsabilité des bulletins
nationale si accaparement de la part
d'une partie de la classe dirigeante par
exemple ça n'est pas la seule
responsabilité des bulles ti nationale
c'est aussi la responsabilité des
africains non oui et non moi je pense
que et moi c'est le modèle qui me pose
problème c'est le modèle qui me pose
problème
et parce que et les politiques et ici
comme ailleurs en fait on a dit aux gens
et dans le cadre de la logique
néolibérale enrichissez-vous c'est ça
que les gens ont entendu et la classe
politique et les milieux d'affaires à
réchy c'est vous et la plupart du temps
effectivement cela se passe et au
détriment du plus grand nombre de ceux
qui n'ont pas pu aller à l'école qui
n'ont pas de relations est toute la
question est de la gouvernance locale
qui est réel et et dépend et de la
gouvernance économique et politique
mondiale elle-même qui impose et au pays
dominés et des modèles et de
développement qui profite d'avoir à leur
propre intérêt quand il est né non non
non généreux donateurs et bailleurs de
fonds vient ici et chaque pays et le
vôtre comme la chine émergents ou vieux
pays industrialisés en crise et paix et
se bat d'abord pour leur intérêt pour
eux et il vient me chercher des parts de
croissance en afrique quand ils disent
que l'afrique que c'est l'avenir c'est
l'avenir du monde c'est d'abord leur
avenir dans le cadre d'une logique
économique et qui veut que et la
présence les pelles
les ingrédients de la croissance en tout
cas sont ici à travers les matières
premières mais aussi les 2 milliard
d'africains en 2050 qui semble poser
problème à ce pays là sont aussi et 2
milliard d'africains majoritairement
jeune c'est aussi des débouchés pour la
plupart des produits de cette grande
entreprise alors vous faites allusion ou
2 milliard d'africains que l'on prévoit
pour en 2050 il faut rappeler qu'en en à
la fin du 19e siècle en afrique il y
avait 100 millions d'habitants c'est une
des raisons il fera semblant la raison
principale pour laquelle ce continent a
été si facile a colonisé par les
européens
c'est qu'il était saoul habitait au
départ aujourd'hui vous êtes 13 fois
plus en cent vingt ans c'est énorme et
10 6 2 milliards la population de
l'afrique subsaharienne pourrait doubler
effectivement et la moitié aurait moins
de 25 ans c'est une révolution
démographique considérable en si peu de
temps
comment vous vous l'imaginez du coup la
population qui double d'ici 10 et 30 ans
d'avoir mais je commence par dire que
oui il ya une étape il faut pas sauter
c'est à dire et la traite négrière qui a
saigné le continent et qui contredit
l'intérieur que la pépite est donc et
coopagri ad'abord m2 et 30 millions de
kilomètres carrés quand vous regardez et
l'étendue l'afrique et imaginer c'est
pas un pays etc des étapes 54 si vous
considérez et l'afrique et la population
de l'afrique dans le cadre d'un modèle
de développement économique qui garantit
la santé l'éducation l'alimentation
l'eau et à l'immense majorité des
africains
le problème de démographie ne se
poserait même pas moi je me souviens je
veux faire partie de cette génération et
qui a cru en son temps la possibilité
d'une maîtrise d
la fécondité de la gestion de cette
question par nous mêmes et sur la base
de nos propres choix que personne ne
nous disent vous avez doit attendre d'un
point quand nous voyons les mêmes pays
se lamenter et du pays est préoccupé par
le vieillissement de la population
alors où est le problème on prétend que
nous faisons nous sommes trop et
l'europe se plaint parce que et elle
elle vieillit alors dans un monde ouvert
si c'est pas un monde raciste qui si
nous sommes tous des ego si chacun peut
circuler et la question de la
démographie africaine doit être posée au
autrement je ne suis pas en train de
dire que nous sommes améliorés de faire
face à la demande de tickets que pour et
la demande sociale et le besoin de
conseils des écoles des hôpitaux de
nourrir débusquer tous ses enfants
c'est un problème mais pour moi c'est
pas le problème numéro un je reviens
toujours à la question du paradigme du
développement
et parlons-en et c'est ce paradigme du
développement qui est pour l'instant
exclue dans l'analyse de notre situation
y compris est quand il s'agit de la
gestion du pot vide
est ce que nous sommes et aujourd'hui et
la manière dont l'union africaine est en
train de déchirer cette question en
mettant la politique et la finance en
avant est-ce que de cette manière et de
d'envisager la relance c'est la relance
d'un modèle économique et dans le
continent et le début de la phase le la
question démographique se pose vous
l'avez dit à la fois pour les africains
mais aussi pour les européens et plus
généralement pour les blancs les
européens au début du 20e siècle à
l'époque où colonisent le monde entier
on est 25 % de la population mondiale
1 une personne sur quatre est blanche
à l'époque quand on sera en 2050 va déjà
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est plus que
15%
même pas et en 2050 on aura affaire à la
chine à l'inde qui sera encore plus
peuplé que la chine et à l'afrique
déjà aujourd'hui plus d'un habitant de
la planète sur deux est asiatique
en 2050 les blancs ne plaideront plus
rien il n'existe quasiment plus est-ce
que mais en même temps vous aurez plus
d'excusé dans ce domaine parce que c'est
souvent c'est souvent une excuse que
vous utilisez la vida traoré mais on
fait une pause et je me laisserais
répondre à la question
juste après on serait trop juste un
point
[Musique]
on continue avec aminata dramane traoré
en direct de bamako au mali sur l'avenir
de l'afrique
je le répète donc 2053 géant
démographique se profile l'inde d'abord
la chine ensuite lan devrait dépasser en
chine
et puis l'afrique avec plus de 2
milliards d'habitants
et puis un monde rétrécit vieilli
l'europe et le monde blanc en général ce
qui était un quart de la population
il ya un siècle ne seront plus que 10 %
peut-être et encore alors là encore ce
renversement comment comment l'imaginez
vous et est ce que ça va pas être la
disparition de des grands responsables
ce qu'on incrimine toujours depuis un
siècle les blancs et pour de bonnes
raisons il avait tous les pouvoirs mais
ils n'auront plus beaucoup d'ici là mais
il semble qu'ils sentent pas incriminer
parce que ils sont nombreux ou parce
qu'ils ont trop de pouvoir
ils sont interpellés par l'usagé qu'ils
font de ce pouvoir
les âges qu'ils font de ce pouvoir
économique politique et technologique et
je pense que est d'abord c'est le milieu
et les designers les transnationales et
qui n'ont pas de nationalité
tout le monde un peu partie prenante
parce que nous avons nous libérer aussi
et qui ne jurent que par le marché par
la place ans et qui croit dur comme fer
que nous allons rattraper la chine mais
en tout cas nous sommes nous en sortir
et dans le cadre du même paradigme donc
moi je n'y crois pas pour un sou mais ce
que je pense par rapport à la
démographie d'avoir je ne sais pas
pourquoi quand on en parle et la
personne n'ose poser la question à la
chine repenser à la chine d'être et
d'avoir plus et plus d'un milliard de
près de 10 milliards de personnes et
perd on n'entend pas tellement parler de
l'inde
mais c'est la question et africaine
c'est pour ça que et ça me fait penser à
cette initiative du g20 et qui veut
absolument venir en aide à la même
afrique précisément l'afrique
subsaharienne en nous prêtant de
l'argent pour gérer et 7 et pandémie et
le président français n'a pas hésité à
dire lors de l'un des sommets du g20 à
hambourg qu'avec tous les milliards du
monde vous ne développez vous pourrez
pas développer l'afrique est temps que
vous n'avez pas maîtrisé et la lettonie
la place entre démographie donc et c'est
pas et si c'est un problème et c'est par
rapport à une conception et du
développement et dans le cadre d'un
modèle imposé la question fondamentale
c'est de savoir et à quel moment as ton
permis à l'afrique de penser son destin
de titres de disposer de ses richesses
de réfléchir à la dimension de la
famille quelle femme quelle famille quel
modèle familial quelle solidarité
c'est-à-dire que est donné en commémore
aujourd'hui et les et l'a libéré le 25
mai en comment mr donc on se remémore
les 57 ans d'existence de l'union et à l
oeil à qui n'a pas trouvé mieux à faire
d'ailleurs que et d'être à la remorque
de l'union européenne au point deux
dates de copier le nom eut lu à tout ça
et on a des atouts ces problèmes sont
est sur la table aujourd'hui et c'est
l'union africaine nos états qui doivent
s'enquérir de l'ip et de ce qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment et c'est
vraiment et de s'inscrire dans des
politiques mimétique qui ne nous en ont
pas vous savez bien pourquoi ça inquiète
les pays européens
quand il parle pour l'afrique de bombe
démographique qu'ils ont peur tout
simplement que comme à chaque fois qu'un
pays pauvres fait des enfants je pense à
l'italie
époque beaucoup de ces enfants partent
et émigrent que ce soit aux états unis
ou en france où les irlandais la même
chose
les anglais à la fin du 19e siècle
reprocher aux irlandais catholiques de
faire trop d'enfants exactement comme
certains aujourd'hui leurs proches aux
africains et et tout le monde a peur
enfin tout le monde non mais certains
ont peur que bas que quand l'afrique
sera 2 milliards et encore je le répète
la moitié aura moins de 25 ans qu'ils
viennent tous qu'ils émigrent en europe
et qu'on multiplie les embarcations sur
la méditerranée vous ne le croyez pas
vous amuser à traoré non parce que c'est
de l'arrogance et de l'inconséquence et
parce que personne ne demande à partir
l'immense majorité de ceux qui sont là
bas qui souffre au quai qui rase le
maire qui vivent dans les conditions que
nous conter savons c'est ces personnes
ne demande même pas
ne demandez pas à partir ne demande pas
rester là-bas l'alternative aujourd'hui
c'est une afrique et qui nourrit
l'afrique et qui pensent l'afrique qui
peut prendre soin de ses enfants
et c'est cette marche de manoeuvre qu'on
n'a pas et qu'on aille pas mary encore
une fois que tout est de notre faute que
c'est les autres avancent et ainsi de
suite et je sais par expérience et vous
savez il ya des rapports de la
commission qui dit que les politiques
d'ajustement structurel et ont été
particulièrement durs et en afrique ici
nous savons il ya énormément de
questions liées et au destin du
continent et il sait des questions
d'ordre démographique on est en train
d'insister là dessus c'est celle à
bruxelles l'économie on en a parlé et
c'est la monnaie et c'est l'écologie et
toutes ces questions brûlantes et qui
d'une actualité brûlante et qui sont au
coeur du débat politique dans vos
démocraties
malheureusement soient évacués d'un
autre c'est pour ça que et quelque part
je disais dans récemment dans l'une de
mes communications que et on paye pour
rester sur le registre et du confinement
et dix de confinement et l'urgence pour
l'afrique aujourd'hui c'est de confirmer
les intelligences permettre aux
africains et 2
ou bien comprendre dans quel monde sans
et quels sont les défis à relever qu est
ce que nous pouvons pour nous-mêmes
qu'est ce que nous pouvons attendre des
autres dans une dans le cadre d'une
coopération et respectueux de nos droits
humains les plus élémentaires
donc la question de la démographie et en
plus pâles et la dissocier et de la
question du modèle économique qui ne
permet même pas et à une classe
politique donnée il ya énormément de
choses à reprocher à cette classe
politique
mais le droit à l'autonomie de pensée
vous avez évoqué on pourra en parler
quand il s'agira de la question
sécuritaire
qu'est-ce que quelle marge de manoeuvre
nous avons si nous décidons aujourd'hui
par rapport dans le cadre de la lutte
contre la pandémie et de changer et de
pratiques de registre de culture
politique de débattre véritablement avec
nos divisions ça ne s'est pas passé nous
avons créé ici une coalition des
artistes et des intellectuels en disant
que nous ne pouvons plus du tête à tête
entre nos dirigeants et leurs
partenaires entre guillemets occidentaux
nous voulons aujourd'hui jouer notre
rôle dans la réflexion sur le continent
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé et le
chef d'état entité est invité pour ne
pas dire convoqué à pau pour aller leur
demander s'ils sont vraiment d'accord
s'il s'agissait de barkan si c'est
vraiment ce que les chefs d'état si le
chef d'état bull ce que une partie des
opinions veulent alors justement parlons
de l'intervention militaire française au
mali qui dure depuis plus de sept ans
sans succès
comment la voyez-vous comment
l'expliquez vous écoutez moi je sais pas
j'ai fait partie de ceux qui dès le
départ ont considéré que la solution à
la situation à laquelle nous étions
confrontés en 2013 la solution n'était
pas militaire
parce que dans le cadre de mai
des combats au niveau du mouvement
social mondial je sais ce qui s'est
passé en irak en afghanistan pourquoi on
entre en guerre on n'entre pas en guerre
et parce qu'on veut survie d'un pays on
entre en guerre parce que les intérêts
dominants l'exigent alors je suis parti
du fait que l alibi ce qui s'est passé
en libye et mettez en péril et la
sécurité la paix la sécurité et dans
notre région plus particulièrement au
mali
à la faveur de l'opération serval serval
et a été transformé en barres quand on
n'a pas demandé l'avis est du mali
ni je ne crois pas de quatre autres pays
du g5 sahel les gens en sont sortis vous
vous souvenez
l'immense majorité des maliens qui n'en
pouvait plus et de la situation créée
dans le nord et par les djihadistes et
donc et la rébellion à l'époque
donc les gens ont cru effectivement que
et la france et libérale piste que comme
et promis ce n'était pas une guerre qui
devait durer
donc comme vous le dites et sept ans
plus tard et barques analyse nous nous
contant nos morts par milliers mais non
j'ai entendu dire que barkan est appelée
à rester au moins 30 ans heffernan le
redoute ici ou dit que ce serait notre
vietnam à nous le mari et vous déjà ne
leur donne pas tort et je ne la donne
pas tort parce que et je crois que je ne
sais pas pourquoi
à quoi tient cet aveuglement et parce
que et là le terreau comme je vous le
dis et le pourrissement de la situation
et économique dans des pays est placé
sous la coupe des institutions
financières mais les politiques et
l'austérité et les politiques et
et nous libéral destructrice qui sont au
coeur du débat politique dans votre
démocratie ce sont ces politiques là et
qui ont engendré la question parce que
et ils ont qu'est-ce-qu'il qu'est ce
qu'ils nous disent l'absence de l'état
et la question des services publics la
corruption et tout y passe tout en
disant si nous quittons et la lega 10
mhz
il s'agit de la sécurité de la france et
de l'europe et même du monde semble
outils mais dit à ma connaissance je ne
crois pas que et les attentats et et que
vous avez subi et que nous déplorons et
les auteurs de ces attentats ne venait
pas du sahel de mon point de vu
l'immense majorité est des gens qui
déjeunent aujourd'hui les recrues en
tout cas est ce qu'ils sont et viennent
d'ici non pas parce qu'ils ont pas
production non pas parce que par
radicalisme nécessairement mais tout
simplement par parce qu'il n'en peut
plus par nécessité
y a pas d'emploi il n'y a pas d'emploi
une emprise
ils sont pas censés partir parce que et
la militarisation obéit à plusieurs
exigences c'est à dire maintenir les
africains les assignés à résidence
vous avez quand j'entends le slogan est
resté chez vous nous l'avons entendu
c'est la première fois que j'ai entendu
et restez chez vous c'est donald tusk
qui le disaient l'alhambra d appliquer
et des gens mais si bien rester chez
vous a maintenant tout le monde c'est
tout le monde reste ce soit on est tous
assignés à résidence
maintenant et barca mais là pour
maintenir chez nous aussi c'est pas
seulement contre les gars disent mais
c'est aussi pour éviter l'émigration est
tout tout tout et puis aussi barré la pl
est barré la route émergents parce que
il ne pas aborder la question et au
sahel et sous l'angle de la géopolitique
et de la bataille de la guerre
économique pour le contrôle des
ressources naturelles de la planète et
c'est faire fausse route
aminata dramane traoré les djihadistes
c'est qui c'est quoi au mali nous on a
l'impression que ce sont des des
terroristes islamistes inféodés à des ch
comme ceux que l'on a combattu avec la
coalition internationale en syrie ou en
irak ou ceux qui ont commis des
attentats en france mais au mali
ce sont des insurgés touareg ou des
terroristes islamistes à fédérer des ch
ce complexe il ya l'inféodation les
têtes pensantes une partie malienne et
donc attaché à une partie internationale
et donc plus récemment d'ailleurs est là
l état islamique et s'est joint est
venue est en train de s'implanter
d'ailleurs il ya une bataille en ce
moment entre et donc al qaïda au maghreb
islamique et l'état islamique au maghreb
et l'état islamique
donc moi je pense que et c'est un
phénomène international et on prétend
que il trouve sa place dans et les ici
le pays notre pays est considéré comme
le ventre au bout parce qu'ils ont pu
s'installer et mai et l'histoire de
cette es2 de 2,7 10 ans et quelques
jolies jambes après qu'un employé le mot
et afghanistan tamise à sion on n'en est
pas là mais je dis que ce la présence
des gars disent au mali a une histoire
et on le sait depuis 2008 ceux qui sont
venus d'algérie qui sont restés pendant
quelques années au nord et qui se sont
intégrés qui n'ont pas pris les armes il
essaie à la suite de l'agression de la
libye par le couple franco britannique
est national et libère les armes venues
de libye
et puis la volonté d'une partie de
soirée deux parties et qui est avec
kadhafi et de revenir et qui a conféré à
la rébellion touareg
une dimension qui n'est pas un qui n'est
plus celle qu'elle a ressenti par le
passé donc nous on a la peau naldo à des
nationaux on a des étrangers et il ya la
possibilité il y avait la possibilité
et et de négocier de parler aux
nationaux c'est ce que certains d'entre
nous avons souhaité depuis longtemps
c'est ce que le président malien
souhaite maintenant parce qu'il y a on
sait que et toutes les parties disons
d'une forte ou comme que lesdits d'une
poigne de détérioration de l'état des
lieux et qui n'est pas seulement lié au
fait que nous ne savons pas développer
notre pays mais comme je voulais be et
toute la marchandisation de notre
société et la marchandisation la manière
dont et l'économie souterraine et s'est
développé ces substituts et est allé
comment il est devenu une sorte de bouée
de sauvetage pour les gens au fur et à
mesure que l'état et se désengager et de
tout à la fois de la création d'emplois
parce que l'état n'était pas censé faire
et quoi que ce soit ni s'occuper et de
la santé de l'éducation et en tout cas
n'en a plus les moyens
et après la mise en oeuvre et de ce
qu'on appelle le consensus de washington
donc il faut situer le mali dans le
contexte est d'une économie est
mondialisée et même la perspective pour
moi c'est une marche forcée vers un
modèle de des coûts de développement et
donne nous n'avons pas les moyens et on
ne souhaite même pas que nous ayons les
moyens et parce que si nous parvenions à
nous développer
et comme d'autres régions du monde je ne
sais pas c'est nicolas bas valais qui le
dit la france par exemple mais rien dans
la mondialisation sans l'afrique le 6 et
10 a dit ce qu'on appelle les
djihadistes si ce sont des terroristes
ou des insurgés ça n'est pas la même
chose s'ils sont des terroristes
il n'y a pas de solution politique il
n'ya qu'une solution militaire
on va pas commencer à discuter à
négocier à se répartir les postes avec
des terroristes en revanche si ce sont
des insurgés
on peut discuter on peut trouver une
solution politique
c'est là où ça a son importance alors
est ce que il n'ya qu'une solution
militaire qu'une solution politique vous
comme vous le dites vous
une solution économique mais une
solution économique c'est dans beaucoup
plus longtemps c'est peut-être plus de
20 ans ou 30 ans là moi je parlerais
surtout d'une solution nationale
sahélienne africaine et sur la base et
d'un gagne aussi qui vous reposer par
nous mêmes parce que jusqu'à présent
c'est pas nous qui à voir et le récit et
la narration tout ce qui se dit à propos
de cette guerre au sahel n'émane pas de
nous les chercheurs les intellectuelles
africaines nous pouvons dire que nous
voulons et les chiens aboient la
caravane passe et il ya un discours
établi depuis le débat la nécessité est
de se positionner militairement ici pour
protéger la france et c'est ça que
d'ailleurs c'est ce que et emmanuel
macron a voulu et faire entendre à
propos du comité car il dit nous sommes
en guerre et vous êtes déjà en guerre
ici mais cette guerre vous ne l'avez pas
réglé vous ne l'avez pas gagnée mais
vous voulez vous maintenir alors je me
demande d'ailleurs j'ai même présent
comment vous allez comment nous allons
pouvoir lutter véritablement contre et
le co vite et parallèlement à la guerre
contre le terrorisme selon le schéma qui
nous coûtent excessivement cher puisque
25% du budget du mali par exemple est
absorbé par ses dépenses militaires
il y avait encore en janvier il ya très
peu de temps mais nous ça nous paraît
très longtemps parce que entre temps il
ya eu le confinement mais en janvier il
ya une éternité
il y avait des manifestations
antifrançaises madame mac os
alors qu on s'en souvient en 2013 quand
les français arrivent ils sont acclamés
sont traités comme des libérateurs
et puis la démultipliée des
manifestations qui se multiplient
qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre les deux
il s'est passé que et la place n'a pas
gagné cette guerre et 4000 morlaix entre
les êtres api mali niger burkina faso et
chaque jour les civils et les militaires
et des armées nationales d'octobre donc
et une partie de l'opinion s'est posé la
question de savoir et à quoi sert bakar
à quoi sert barkan est d'autant plus que
et les gens pouvaient ceux qui pleurent
leurs morts et par dizaines par
centaines voit que est mort français
c'est semble susciter beaucoup plus de
compassion que lorsque tout tous ces
jeunes licenciés du même âge et nous
nous comprenons la douleur des parents
là bas et qui sont les mêmes partout
je respecte ces morts mais on ne nous
expliquons pas et c'est pas de
l'indifférence mais 4000 c'est-à-dire
4000 dhs en quelques mois et le
ras-le-bol quoi les gens n'en peut plus
d'autant plus que dans toutes ces zones
là non seulement les gens ne circulent
plus librement et les l'économie tout ce
qu' une bonne partie des réalités qui
découpe du corps vide
en fait c'est le vécu et d'une partie
des populations ça et bien et occupez
aujourd'hui il par les militaires
il qu'il s'agisse et de barkan ou des
terroristes et les groupes armés et
attaquent des villages les gens ne peut
plus aller régulièrement les marchés
hebdomadaires les gens ne peut pas les
et peu pâlot champ il peut pas en fait
et il s'écrit et l'absence de l'état que
les gens déplore qui est une réalité
mais qui a aussi une histoire et à
inciter et disons les islamistes et à
yaya on le sert d'ailleurs une sorte
d'alternative islamiste a opposé et au
même modèle et qui ne tient pas ses
promesses
c'est pour ça que moi je me dis et on
peut il faut pas saucissonner et les
problématiques
il faut procéder à une approche globale
et systémique qui consiste à dire qu'il
ya une lame de fond qui est un modèle de
développement indépendant extravertie
qui ne profite pas aux africains qui a
créé un certain nombre de gros problèmes
chômage et pauvreté de masse migrations
forcées et conflits et autour des
ressources naturelles et le djihadisme
parce que et comme je vous dis c'est une
forme d'insurrection
je dirais même pas de désespoir parce
que peut-être que la plupart des jeunes
qui se laissent recruter n'ont même pas
d'interlocuteur il n'y a pas de lieu
pour débattre de ces questions pour que
les gens sachent à tous les niveaux mais
qu'est ce qui nous arrive pour que nous
ne nous en sortons pas pourquoi nous
n'avons pas de marché nous ne vendons
pas pourquoi ce sont nos marchés sont
inondés et de produits qui nous ne
transformons pas localement économie
donc la sortie est de la praire covin et
l'afrique de la prep au vide et
aujourd'hui et pour que nous puissions
europe avec avec cette descente aux
enfers de certains pays et en tout cas
de la bande sahélienne mais je crois que
la question est valable pour tous les
pays qui sont en guerre aujourd'hui
contraints
face à la foi et à la guerre et à tout
autre péril dans le convive
il faut mettre à plat le paradigme du
développement c'est à dire et le
capitalisme est sous sa forme actuelle
et qui a un véritable désastre pour
l'afrique
dernière question aminata traoré le
franc cfa vestiges de la colonisation il
existait depuis le lendemain de la
seconde guerre mondiale vestiges aussi
de la françafrique
le franc cfa disparaît il va être
remplacé incessamment par l'écho qui
sera toujours en parité fixe avec l'euro
mais la france se retire des instances
de gouvernance et la bceao la banque
centrale des états d'afrique de l'ouest
ne devra plus déposer la moitié de ses
réserves de changes à la banque de
france comme elle l était tenu de le
faire du temps du franc cfa
c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est bien mais
je crois qu'elle peut mieux mieux et
qu'elle se fasse encore un effort et
parce que et le projet de l'ipo était un
projet de la cedeao un projet
panafricain mais nous avons nous sommes
nombreux à penser que la france a coupé
l'herbe sous les pieds des africains
pourrait adopter un niveau qui va
s'inscrire dans le cadre d'une logique
économique où elle demeure gagnante donc
etc c'est ce complexe et nous avons
organisé ici à bamako et à d'autres
niveaux et pas mal de réflexion sur
cette question de la souveraineté
monétaire qui rejoint les autres
questions la souveraineté territoriale
militaires économiques politiques
mais la monnaie etc
le nerf de la guerre et c'est clair que
et la question de l'endettement du
désendettement et et toutes ces
questions sont saunier et je pense que
le fait que et la décision émane de la
france tout seul quand on apprend comme
ça explique beaucoup de choses c'est
aussi la question de la dette la
création de la monnaie et tout va et
tout et tout et tout est là quoi comme
un des crises sanitaires crise
économique crise sociale qu'est sur mon
était en train de tout est sur la table
alors profitons en pour faire de telle
sorte que vraiment c'est ce ce midi ce
tueur est révélateur et des échecs d'un
système prétendument infaillible et non
un site et à davantage de sagesse quoi
on n'a pas posé la question de
l'écologie et qui est aussi une question
un défi considérable surtout est ici
d'où je parle de ça y est on est
interpellé frédéric par toutes ces
questions là et c'est important mais
nous l'africa et les six il s'agit parce
que le vide le défi le véritable défi
qui nous interpelle dans le cadre de
cette crise c'est la capacité de penser
le monde est dedans et en termine à
l'avantagé des humains c'est à dire
comment faire de telles choses que et la
logique de profit de primes plus sur la
vie donc et dans le car s'il s'agit
d'une véritable réflexion sur l'humain
sa place et ce qu'il peut pour lui-même
je vous assure que et l'afrique a des
ressources est porteuse de solutions
quand il de la culture merci
j'ai proposé et je terminerai des lic
donc les faveurs de répondre à nos
portes à des dépenses et y allait
développer quelque chose mais on aura le
temps une autre fois avec plaisir
merci aminata dramane traoré d'avoir
passé une heure avec nous je vois qu'il
ya de belles lumières de fin
d'après-midi sur bamako qui apparaît à
travers vos rideaux merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]